nein nein nein geht raus geholt
ein 1 1 1 0
herzlich willkommen zu einer
beziehungsweise mehreren runden super
job und mit dabei ist heute der crafter
und wir werden das heute rocken genau wo
und würde daraus eine kleine challenge
machen
wir werden ein best of five spielen das
heißt wer zuerst drei siege hat ist der
king im ring und gewinnt die
weltherrschaft und ich würde sagen lasst
uns doch einfach mal loslegen
das war das mein befehlen nicht alles
war dann befehle dir ja die mir direct
group ist immer am anfang ok also jörg
best of three
und wer verliert ist einfach einfach ein
user deswegen wollen wir das nicht so es
gibt natürlich sind auch schalte ich bin
auch umhört sagen es sei wahrscheinlich
verlieren und deshalb ist am loser aber
was er wird auch noch verlieren schnell
die inhalte nicht viel abgestürzt sagt
man man kann hier aber so ein paar
abkürzung machen weil ein paar sprünge
kann man aus lassen kannst du krass
aufholen
wir wollen 5 wir waren fünf und machen
da kann man doch nur die kleinen spielen
also ganz logisch und es gibt nicht so
viele große was los hier
ihr müsst mich verarschen was geht hier
ab alter ist auch fakt ist abgepackt
nein nein nein ich bin grad kurz vorm
ziel sie ist mit nicht ok schade mir
geht richtig die party gerade irgendwie
so abgepackt ja sehr gut jetzt den
einspruch von 66 81 jetzt leute wir
müssen jetzt einfach mal konzentrieren
ich bin ich auch die ganze zeit
abgehalten hätte kamera nicht abkaufen
das ist der letzte champion abgucken
kann ich glaube ich hab's geschafft
ich glaube ich warte noch ein bisschen
den kopf
weißt du was ihr macht nochmal spannend
ich bin einfach toll almosen style
online
sag mal im monat
nonstop lauf die leute und dann
wesentlich zu sehr pausen bürger zum
shoppen und das wird mir zum verhängnis
und leider leider ich jetzt einfach
machen soll verhindert nicht gereicht ja
genau überheblichkeit komplex beiden
fonds für beide von uns in amerika aber
ich mache ich mache nie pausen wenn ich
laufe ja echt nicht ich glaube ich bin
immer streckt alter endlich ich weiß
nicht mehr dass kennt leute hat
das manchmal dass euer kopf einfach zu
viele formulierungen hat für eine sache
und das sie dann so ein mischmasch
daraus macht dass man ständig ämter
richtig ankommen und was ich spiele
meistens wird darüber sprechen stehen
den arenen die karte ist auch super
kurzoper an gelenken
1 1 steht es stimmt ja erstmal okay mit
essen abgepackt
das schaffe meine augen machen gerade
sache nicht segura de gott ich habe
einen richtigen lauf was und ich sage ja
geil wenn sie mal zurückgesetzt tui sie
vor oder er nicht ran kraft würde ich
mal zurückgesetzt hier so oder nicht ist
egal
da weißt du wer dort gewann hat ja ja ja
klar
biggs hat der junge ich probiere ich
zurückgefragt ist dir nichts man kann
kommen zwei leute ich hatte kurz einen
seltsamen hänger und mit guter
ausnahmsweise mal kommen hinter gitter
ich habe leider keine ahnung mehr was
noch eine kurze karte ist manchmal hatte
ich war einfach mal welches gibt super
job
du kannst kannst du machen sollst du
kannst kanada wollte ein paar wochen
kommt ab die kann ich nämlich habe extra
andere als gleicher partner ausgewählt
habe das jetzt nicht zu lang gibt lacht
quatscht werden juni gezeigt da habe ich
sogar ich habe also sogar noch gute
zeitalter an das love bamboo der dbbl
libyen halten
die wollen beginnen einfach nur dass die
wahlen so ich habe im moment ganz gut
das hat man
nein die arena station in die kommentare
obwohl die sie für krankheiten wie sie
das schon die entscheidung
kannst dann ehre wiederherstellen
irgendwelche aussagen verzögern können 8
die karte die kenne ich okay sie für
wieder müssen das putzen alter wir
müssen uns jetzt pushen
wenn du nicht war es damals ein video
hochladen wie du 50 liegestützen kann
aber noch sehen
ich kann 15 die beginnen wollen näher
kukla die effekte alter der auch noch
mal so durch gucken ab heute guckt ihn
euch an darfst du immer stehen oder was
ja natürlich
da wird man ja heute so ein grausiger
tag und ich habe heute immer gewonnen
und drüben nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein
man bat noch kurz lancierte dabei
schnell gewinnen wir können andere war
stunde machen willst die wache jetzt
einfach best of seven alter wir schauen
nicht so lange bis 15
machen wir machen wieder angefangen
haben hier meine krankheit
kein dreispringer auslassen jetzt machen
die ganz wird neue bestzeit
es wird neue bestzeit war top show
gottschalk kommt schon den ersten kommt
schon kommt schon kommt schon mal
hinabgestürzt
nein im ernst wer gemacht jetzt sicher
wieder abgelassen stets jetzt 433 machen
wir doch lieber besten wir als erstes
518 best of seven ja dann kommt es nur
eine runde gewünscht
du darfst du dir wünschen kann es nicht
wissen kann freundlich hast dich und wir
machen jetzt einfach mal ich kann jeder
weg was die kenne ich nicht kenne die
kann ich zwar halbwegs als ich habe ewig
kein super gespielt heute aber die gome
hd server sind heute down down wie mein
ok centrum bank x peter sie viele jahre
lebte schon her da war war fand
vorsprung in der decke super da hab ich
auf den vorletzten sprung in den
schwierigsten von allen
es geht um alles ich hab's ja nein
gesagt
7 hat oder wir machen jetzt auch pause
mutiger als bei einem match machen wir
noch spielen kann oder was beim fiat
panda aufgelegt alles oder nichts
navigation ist neuer doppelt oder nein
alles oder nichts heißt wenn ich gewinne
habe ich gewonnen wenn du verlierst habe
ich auch gewonnen
es klingt spitze
die maschine vom kann man noch gar nicht
durch die kann man gar nicht ohne
abspringen wenn man sich da drehen muss
nein hab ich einen kompletten knick im
archiv erkrankt
ach ja ich höre das ist der klassiker
also was jetzt ja okay wie gesagt die es
ohne grad das heißt ich habe gewonnen
leute wenn sich gefahr anlass einen
daumen nach oben in der beschreibung und
schreib mir einen kommentar unter dem
video
schreibt eure zeit für die panda 16
sekunden
ich habe 15 leute wenn ihr auch mal
retten wollt dann sehen was beim
nächsten video wieder war dass sich eine
tolle leistung max haut rein und